ich habe gerade wieder die punkte
gefunden drei stück ich bin echter
punkte ich bin der absolute punkte
hallo ich meine lieben freunde wir
befinden uns gerade live in goma hat das
gehirn wo bist du ich hab nach 52 mal
eine kleine zuschauer mal wieder ein
denke ich denn geben gerade ich hatte so
ein verdammtes glück
ich habe eine kiste gefunden da waren
zwei punkte drin damit wirklich
normalerweise und stoppt mit den
schnäbeln sage ich später dann hätte ich
ja normalerweise drei punkte gehabt gut
ich hatte die noch in der kiste stehen
gelassen ja schau mal und ich hatte die
in der kiste noch liegen gelassen weil
ich mich einfach gefeiert habe ich bin
ihrem zimmer brüllend rumgelaufen hab
ich gefeiert dafür dass sich da zwei
punkte gefunden habe von kraft aber noch
hinter mir ich hab mich gefeiert
was kommt ich möchte gerade rausnehmen
kontraste kommt an cloud mir die punkte
aus der kiste
dann hat er mich mit dem schneeball von
einer klippe herunter geschlagen
mit diesem epischen schneeball muss man
sagen der hat irgendwie noch beck 20
nicht täusche richtig episch und ich
habe keine günstige von mit drei gast
drehen
ich habe drei punkte es kann schon
wieder bisher ok setze ich meine
geschichte mal welche teams einig öffne
das nicht was drin
und bei mir war so ich habe noch eine
kiste gefunden schon wieder zwei punkte
drin ich habe dir genommen bin dabei
einem sprung gefehlt hat mich ende im
flug nach unten in richtung von crafter
gepostet war bei konkreter bin dann bei
ihnen gestorben er hat alle meine punkte
bekommen wie viele punkte hast du gerade
77 punkte leute hier erst fünf stück von
mir 54 stück hast du locker von mir eine
punkten
ja weil ich habe so viele kisten auch
geöffneten ich hab's einfach so verdient
auch paprika nicht informieren die kiste
aber das war auf jeden fall mega ähnlich
ich habe grade schon wieder die punkte
gefunden drei stück ich bin ein echter
punkte kam
ich bin da absolute punkte ich bin schon
du kannst ja mal zu mir porten ich
glaube du bist deswegen einfach auch so
weit weil du dich mal bord ist egal ob
wohin ich war schon wieder ganz weit und
antwortet er sich einfach zur vor der
aufnahme zu mir und dann hast du bist
gar nicht so schnell
wir kommen wieder diesen ganz auf
gebügelter fuß ist das genau ich denke
wie wir auch eine andere folge
besprochen haben
ich denke immer bevor ich eng wie
sprechender mache ich ja immer ich denke
so viel unbedingt richtig vielen opfer
tief heruntergefallen
aber ich hab drei punkten möchte ich
noch anmerken ja das ist unglaublich
noch richtig krank was für ein glück
hast weiß ich schlafe mit dem schneeball
weg und er findet dann eine kiste und
ich habe schon wieder drei punkte
wenn ich da meine kiste findet dann auch
richtig heftig was da alles drin ist so
you can say your girlfriend already des
users trend out of the friends so ok und
gerade stand ihr meine mutter so in fünf
minuten komme in fünf minuten gibts ja
essen
da hab ich gesagt nee nee nee ich muss
ja aufnehmen wieder nicht dadurch sind
mario pilze ich komme dann gleich mario
allerdings heute komme ich hier sogar
für uns er fastet für uns wieder
aufnehmen kann
nur wegen ein paar punkte finden möchte
schießen hat ein budget winterlauf
signals von crafter ich bin gerade
richtig überdreht wie weinreisen hierfür
noch rüstung bitte lol und schön in pink
richtig männlich ich packe jetzt erst
mal als sachen rein ich nicht brauche
die punkte die brauchst du dich und die
schilder packe ich da ist rechten irene
alt wirst du sterben
nein hätte sein können hätte ja sein
können wirklich haben wir da noch ein
wie nahrung ich hatte keine tochter mit
nahrung fundiert alter ich habe drei
punkte schrauben holz stoppen ich habe
mir nicht aufgehört zu brennen flippte
levels and some love cygnet to help you
find that might be dangerous ok ich
warte lieber noch mal auf dich mit dem
schalter oder drückt oberliga den
schalter ich leide immer noch was ist
weil du hast ja die aufnahme zu schwer
aufzubringen fällt mir springt ich
verzichte jetzt hat wenn du einmal
geschlagen drücken wir mal wird in den
gefährlichen schalter ersten tor war
komplett man jährlich kiste cookbook
shop keine böse monster in eine kiste
finde ich hier noch irgendwo ich bin
gerade auf der suche nach einer kiste
harten check point alter das ich dir
auch immer die checkpoints aufmachen
dass sein immer über drei weil ich
konnte immer jedes mal leute sind so
viele monster ich will gar nicht mehr
listen sie werden mir vor dass ich oben
drauf bin
neumann kandiert blöcke mit einem schlag
kaputt machen
ok com ist der punkte geil und ich bin
hier mehr so der probe die stadt nicht
alles der glück wurden schöne aufnahme
da auf jeden fall wo man lebt nur einmal
heute in freund getroffene der dauernd
so juli ich so zudem weist über jede
sache hat er immer gesagt you know
you're damit ihm gesagt weil es über
barcelona bedeutet
ich möchte nachher noch mal googeln
er sagt die auch scheiße man lernt
gelitten auch vor ein paar tagen nicht
alle meine freunde bin runter gefallen
hier sind jedoch alles ich dass ich
überleben alter ich helfe man nicht
heftig hälfte von rambus auch hier hätte
ich kann also viele freunde von mir
kennen leider meinen youtube-kanal ich
wollte das eigentlich noch etwas länger
so verbergen sagt mal etwas mehr auf
normal machen so aber auf jeden fall
kann dann bei deiner heute in der schule
an
das vergisst dann glaube ich ihm und
redet also ja ich lasse nicht minecraft
gekauft ich so ja habe ich
weißt du eigentlich minecraft da habe
ich mir mein zweiter kommt genannt alexa
und du kannst hier schon m
ja das ist wohl viele auf jeden fall hat
gesagt ja ich bin immer auf dem mit dem
server und der server gehört mir ja auf
jeden fall ich so jung kann ich und ich
kann auch den youtuber sagte kummer hat
sie heißt ich so aha etwas du kannst du
den auch ja klar habe ich ihm gesagt er
kenne ich auch eng blieb er hat mich der
hat gesagt er hat mich nicht
wiedererkannt
heute nach einem tag kam dann bei mir an
eigentlich weiß ich warum er nach einem
tag bei mann kam kein platt nach wegen
das story entweder einen folgen habe ich
nämlich eine geschichte erzählt die ich
in meiner schule genau erzählt habe auch
verdammt data hat habe ich mich auch
gefunden jetzt schaute mich meine videos
aber hat mich nie das erkannt denke auf
jeden fall kann man heute an bis zum
sommer soll dann das sich erst mal voll
gefeiert
also bei mir bei mir kennen nicht auch
relativ viele eigentlich zum
mittlerweile und ich werd teilweise bei
youtube von leuten angeschrieben so
meinen ja ich wurden hier in der
nachbarstadt meine leute dass du da und
auf die schule gestimmt hat und jetzt zu
alter warum also keine anmeldung ist
lässt sich halbzeit mehr verheimlichen
ich will jetzt auch nicht das nicht so
eine große glocke hängt man macht halt
später werde man alles also so schlimm
finde ich auch nicht schlimm
wo rennst du gerade rennen wirklich alle
läuft wieder zurück an anfang aber karte
laden wurde zwei gas tränen gefunden 99
stück und warum habe ich denke ich
gerade eben geholfen man wärst du
gestorben und
ich hab ja auch gefragt ich helfe ihr
euch denken sie warum das weil ich
einfach ein hilfsbereiter mensch wenn
ich ganz eingeschränkt ist jetzt an
machen das jetzt hier eigentlich bis zum
anfang ein jackpot am 8 aha also noch
nicht fokussiert dass zombies und
monster ja sicher ja ich bin auch schon
so weit gekommen wir noch weitergekommen
danach ihre aufgabe stellen dann bin ich
irgendwie unter gefallen weil ich das
alles in einem mal lösen wollte ok
hierüber gut so seine kleine strecken an
ich glaube wenn eigentlich wild wird
einfach sagen wenn einer runter fällt
bleibt der andere automatisch damit sich
der andere porten kann so kann sich
button wir haben caprima weiterspinnen
mal vor ich bin katar gifte machte man
bei ok dann kannst du gar nicht springen
oder wie erwartet ganz kurz schau mal
wie weit ich so geht wieder gut ich
mache auch weiter alter wie viele hinter
dir her sind ich bin runter gefallen
wird stehen okay bei dir nicht noch
weiter ich täglich so das geht ja noch
die sprünge jetzt kommen oder gefallen
dadurch bin ich bin bei dir bin bei dir
postshop stopp stopp stopp orte die
schnelle hab ich das war heftig vergifte
auch gerade
aber man goldenen apfel es passt dass
wir hätten es uns vielleicht irgendwie
milch leider nicht ob und wo er denn
billig wir sind hier weil ich mache
weiter okay ich mache weiter
ja geschafft es ist echt krank wie
schlitten sind
ach so ich war wir stehen macht immer
weiter wartet auf dich
es ist echt heftig so was ja gut frame
ein solches okay ich springen weiter
machst du geschafft rund geschafft wo
wir auch mein glück hier lang gelang
nach history bei gas tränen ich habe elf
angeber wenn man einmal fisch erst
flashpoint wenn ich einmal sterben
ich bin noch nie gestorben
aber noch weiter gedrückt ja schon das
warten checkpoint hätte dich getötet
wieder checkpoint durch and roll
das war richtig klasse so viele punkte
nur durch mich nein so weit ich hab's
schüler geschafft aber du hast
pragmatisch ergattert ja ja unglaublich
das war bei lewis aber dass du diese
diese punkte überhaupt alle so gekriegt
heißt es war so klug wie genommen habe
das nenne ich lege mich die waren in der
kiste ich habe dir einfach nicht raus
genommen hab ich erstmal gefeiert und
dann und dass ich mir die genommen hat
das weiterkommen haben
eiskalt weil ich war kein computer ich
habe schon gesehen dass du hinter mir
eingestanden
ich hab' ich wollte gerade mit dem
ausruf gehen war zu spät waren schon weg
und dann der moment dann der moment des
sieges war so episch
das war so schrecken oft große positiv
okay wir müssen jetzt wieder über
kakteen springen enorm nein ich hasse
kapitän sprünge cook schicken es hier
drin
wer liebt die dann auch schon ich auf
jeden fall nicht was magst du lieber an
kakteen sprünge oder er leiter sprünge
er leiter sprünge ok wack den sparer
nicht die wir von allem obwohl ich es
geschafft habe
aber nicht doch verstärkt soll ich hab
schon wieder ein checkpoint geöffnet gut
gut gut doch jetzt und wie gefällt er
die karte so kleiner zwischenstand also
ich würde sagen eigentlich ich finde
karte bisher 1 1 gegen eine glatte eins
ich finde es echt genial gerade ich
hoffe man auch der spaßfaktor hier der
wahre hexer schon geschafft ja ich will
wieder gefallen guck da oben sind so
groß gute leistung okay dann werde drei
minuten konnten die vier irgendwann und
ein abstauber die rüstung da an uns
gedacht glaube ich mit der rüstung kann
man hier gleich sterben
nein auf dem sprung zum gebäude des 1
238 verdammt sprint kann man auch
einfach über bei dem erz verhältnis das
3 ein wunderschöner sondern teilersatz
eine also ironisch gemeint sind total
viele leider ich hatte schon bei mir ist
ein wechsel ist aber bei mir sind
einfach total verändert haben weg etwas
wahr was mich geschlagen wie ich hab
dich geschlagen
was mich geschlagen
jetzt auch alter zu manner leit ich hab
dich nur mit schneeball ab getroffen
tut mir leid da sie so viel kraft auf
das zu machen schneeball wovon mir so
weit fliegt aber mein bizeps ist einfach
er muss ja wirklich beim 60 ja noch cool
sommer ich schaffe das nicht ich hab ja
ich habe es noch nicht aber ich würde
auch sagen dass ihm in der nächsten
folge wieder mal bei mir immer waren wir
genau
nein
schaut euch das an diese ganzen sachen
die das ist